a few weeks ago we began a journey
together
i want to laugh at a feminist comedian
not at them
i mean i i can laugh at them that's very
easy to do
but with them i want to find a funny
joke told by a feminist comedian
and laugh at it you will
fail
that's my goal in life that's the only
thing i want to achieve before i die
i've done everything else
that i want to do sadly enough this is
the last thing so first we tried
samantha b
that was a miserable failure uh didn't
work out so today we're gonna bring out
the big guns
hannah gadsby okay hannah gatsby's the
acclaimed
beloved critical darling the best
feminist comedian
currently on the scene i'm told so we're
gonna watch some of her clips
and uh see if we can do this you know
can i laugh at a hannah gatsby joke
can we laugh let's find out together
come along friends
forget i did that sorry
now i want to tell you a story about a
terrible conversation i had
at the dog park once this bloke just
walks up to me i mean he had a dog he
wasn't just being creepy he had context
and i want to tell you this it's not
pertinent to the story but i want you to
know his dog
had shoes on and his dog did not want to
have shoes on
because he's doing that like and it was
a whippet situation and they're shaking
at the best of times
we don't know why are they cold or they
nervous we don't know but it was like
just
it was a lot now it's not important to
the story but it was a lot in my
periphery so i just want you to know
added stress okay well you know a dog
with shoes that's uh
see that that's kind of funny i'm i'm
not a laugh thing i'm not gonna
you know not laughing level but i mean
actually seeing the dog with shoes
that would get a laugh at me if she had
a if she had a picture she could have
showed us
you know the visual probably would have
helped but uh
simply mentioning the dog with shoes
isn't enough but i'm i'm
i'm on the verge of laughing okay the
dog with shoes okay she's loosing me up
a little bit
i'm ready to laugh i want to laugh i'm
in a laughing mood now i'm thinking
about dogs with shoes
and um now she just has to go in for the
kill so let's let's see let's see what
she's got
now this was my uh friend's icebreaker
we'd never met this was his icebreaker
he said did you know
it takes less muscles to smile than
frown
now the men in the audience are sitting
there going oh you've experienced an
isolated incident
when the women are sitting there going
oh [ __ ] sake
and non-binary folk are like is that a
hard day for you is it damn it
she squandered it you squandered it
hannah you you i was ready to laugh i
was you had me
you had me why hannah why
i mean now she's going into the
absolutely insufferable feminist
harangue about being told to smile
and of course she throws in the thing
about non-binary folks because
you know she can't make a man vs woman
joke without acknowledging the invented
non-binary category
and that's good obviously because
diversity inclusion political
correctness
all the stuff that makes comedy great
okay uh dare i
even continue playing this i have a bad
feeling now i just before i was filled
with hope
dog with shoes now she's going into the
feminist thing uh i should have been
prepared for this it is a feminist
comedian after all
i wasn't ready it turns out i'll play a
little bit more let's see how much more
we can
stomach now as far as icebreakers go
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] one
basically what he's saying is your face
is wrong can you change it
like honestly and even if i was gave him
the benefit
of the doubt right and truly believe
that energy consumption was his
chief concern that he was just looking
at me going if only she knew
she could live her best life she could
get so much more out of a day if only
she knew like even if i believed that
the thing is i was neither smiling nor
frowning
my face was neutral which takes [ __ ] all
muscles like and now i am aware that my
neutral face is not particularly chipper
like i do look like someone stabbed the
potato with a spoon upside down honestly
like
no muscles neutral
now i have resting face that's what it's
called it's what's colloquially known as
resting
face only women have resting [ __ ] face
men
simply have very important thoughts you
best not interrupt them having
like honestly no one has ever gone up to
a man what he's a stranger and gone
cheer up love may never happen
no okay all right just stop i can't this
this i mean i'm waiting for the joke
here i'm way
the the potato what is that i
potato with a fork in it upside down i
don't know
um she is a community comedian right so
there's supposed to be some humor but
it's not really happening instead she's
just
venting about a perceived personal
slight i feel like this is 2003 and i'm
listening to somebody read their live
journal entry to me out loud
and can i just say for the record for
all you women out there
just so you know a little bit of
mansplaining okay
actually you are not being specially
targeted when people tell you to smile
you really aren't
men do get the same thing all the time
so hannah says
no would ever say this to a man yes they
would
actually they do people say to me all
the time
if you can imagine i don't like it it's
annoying but then again i don't like it
when anyone says anything to me about
anything ever so
i'm not the best judge but the only
reason why you ladies
think that the smile thing is sexist and
that you're being specially targeted
is that you ladies are the only ones
whining about it now i'm going to go off
on my own
harangue there are many things that
feminists complain about where they they
think that women are the only ones that
deal with it
no it's not that women are the only ones
that deal with it it's just that women
are the only ones who complain about it
all the time
everybody else we just keep it to
ourselves so
you know when someone says that to a man
we just shrug it off and go about our
day meanwhile
someone says it to hannah gadsby and she
does a she does a netflix special about
it
my god this is pettiness on steroids and
i say that as someone who has written
multiple thousand plus word articles
complaining about people who don't put
their shopping carts away in grocery
store parking lots
there is no greater evidence of the of
the disintegration
of human society than shopping carts
that people just leave
all over a parking lot so i know
something about petty whining
and this out does even me all right
let's uh
let's try another one and they can put a
stand in because i won't hold things
this shape anymore
i know who i am i know my strengths
because she's a she's a lesbian i don't
know did you get it
did you get the joke there it's the
no no no no hold on listen listen test
up did you get it i don't think you got
it it's
she's a lesbian so she only mentions it
19 times per minute when she's on stage
so you might you might not have picked
up on it lesbians lesbians
lesbian lesbians lesbians but uh yeah
she is a lesbian that's the joke there
so let's
continue i'm not good at representing
i haven't even read the agenda
i haven't read the gay agenda i keep
hearing rumors and i think i don't wanna
no it sounds bad
so it sounds like i might be in
slytherin
now hang on wait a second i'm
i'm sorry i i don't mean to get into
conspiracy theorists here conspiracy
theories but i
i simply don't believe
that the audience is laughing that hard
at that joke
i don't there is no way because
it's a hair it's a harry potter
reference right this is how in touch i
am
with the youth of today uh slytherins
are happy so
there's no way that a harry potter
reference could cause someone to break
into uncontrollable fits of laughter
i don't i don't believe it the physical
reaction doesn't make sense
it would be like if someone responded
with orgasmic delight
after taking a bite out of a out of like
a graham cracker
or something that there's no way that a
graham cracker could elicit that sort of
response
unless you were starving in the desert
for two weeks and then you had a graham
cracker then maybe it would have that
kind of reaction so
were these people were they locked in a
dungeon and not allowed to laugh on pain
of torture for two years
and then could that explain it because
then i guess you'd be so pleased that
you're allowed to laugh that you would
laugh even at a hannah gatsby
harry potter reference so maybe that's
the secret of her success that she
requires her audience to be chained in a
dungeon for 24 months
prior to attending her performance i
don't know you know a lot of people
people have different theories that's
mine
uh who knows anyway um all i'm saying is
that
i actually want to laugh and that that
is not
this is called try to laugh and i'm
trying to laugh but i can't laugh at
that at least not
at least not that much the most that
that joke could really get out of a
normal person as sort of like a
oh harry potter oh from harry potter
right sure sure yeah i get it yeah
funny funny that's one of those jokes
where you just use
you have to say your reaction because
you can't actually exhibit it
oh funny sure yeah harry potter all
right i'm going to give up on this one
as i am rapidly giving up on life itself
let's give this a shot
but in all the debate about
homosexuality
um no one ever really talked about the
lesbians
lesbian uh did you did you pick up do i
have to play it again
just as a reminder lesbian she's a she
is a lesbian
um all right do you know like it's all
the gay men they're the problem
i know sex that's when the devil gets
if i were to transcribe this and show it
to you in written form
and tell you that it's a transcription
from a therapy session that i was
eavesdropping on you would absolutely
believe me
you there there'd be almost nothing in
it that would give you that would give
away
the secret that this is actually a
stand-up comedian
performing for a sold-out audience
but because this is simply a woman
working through her feelings on stage
but the problem is if i want to listen
to a woman work through her feelings
i can just go and talk to literally any
woman ever and they'll be happy to
oblige i
i don't need to watch stand-up comedy
for that i have a wife for god's sake
okay um all right new video i'm going to
abandon i'm not going to abandon the
mission just yet
i'm not going awol but i i am determined
still to laugh at a hannah gatsby joke
so
if only i can find one some people think
it's strange that i would take the pill
as a as a lesbian a spoiler alert
i did you wait i just need to stop it
there for a second because
this is breaking news okay
hannah gadsby is a lesbian
wow wow i know your disappointment's
palpable mate
why would you need to take the pill but
i do need to take the pill people
i do because sometimes i like to dress
[ __ ]
i do i love to [ __ ] it up i really do
show a bit of ankle stop it yes
let's stop it right there look at this
shot of the audience these these girls
in the audience
you know the book animorphs on the cover
where they
show the transition the transition from
the person into what
this looks like a transition where the
girl on the left is like
beca each each shot is her becoming the
one all the way on the far
right maybe is the audience populated by
clones that's the theory i'm getting
here
to here maybe there are there's like a
stash of
clones somewhere and their only role is
just to they they fill the audience and
they laugh at hannah gatsby jokes
maybe you know we're we're solving the
mystery as we go along here
let's go uh okay i'm gonna abandon this
i'm just clicking through we're going
through we're going through videos
here's one right here
now this one okay this one looks like
this is a speech it's not really
a stand-up comedy
performance but i don't see a difference
anyway between
every standard county performance
rehearsal speech so
let's let's give this one a shot i find
good men talking about
bad men incredibly irritating
and this is something the good men are
doing a lot of
at the moment not this moment not this
minute
because the good men don't have to wake
up early
for their opportunity to monologue their
hot take on misogyny
all right shut up just just shut up uh
sorry i'm getting frustrated here this
is
i'm supposed to be laughing not angry
maybe this this i i admit part of this
might be me part of the problem might be
me maybe it's it's
it's not you hannah gatsby it's me maybe
i don't know you guys tell me is this is
this hilarious are you laughing at this
hey hell no okay last one oh [ __ ] quit
i'm a disgrace
okay you said it not me hannah
i didn't say that i don't disagree
but i didn't say it what sort of
comedian can't even make the lesbians
laugh
every comedian ever
see that's that's actually kind of a
good joke i you know i
almost feel a laugh burbling up inside
me
it's either a laugh or the chipotle i
had for lunch i don't but it's it i
it's a it's not a bad she's gone back to
the lesbian well again we can't you know
we're not gonna hold that against her
we're past that now that's all she's got
talk about what you know this is what
she knows and pretty much
only this fine um but i like the joke
because it's it's
it's you know it's a it's a joke it's an
actual joke
from a comedian and so that's progress
we're getting somewhere
uh okay now let's let's see if she can
finally take us home
very clever joke i i didn't write that
that is not my joke
oh come on
that one kind of good joke and it wasn't
even her joke
man the one decent joke we've heard this
entire time and it's not hers i feel
betrayed
and disappointed and and and depressed
it's an old an oldie old bit of goldie a
classic
it was written you know well before even
women were funny
um and uh back then
in the good old days uh lesbian meant
something different than it does now
back then lesbian wasn't about sexuality
a lesbian was just any woman not
laughing at a man
why aren't you laughing what are you
some kind of lesbian
classic god you gotta laugh you gotta
lighten up
stop taking everything so seriously and
learn to take a joke you need a lighten
tell you what you need you need a line
up and tell
who is she imitating right now who is
this person that she's
what when when in her life has anyone
ever said anything like that to her i
guarantee
never is that supposed to be the joke
maybe it is is the joke here that
feminists are hysterical and
oversensitive and constantly imagining
that they're being persecuted when
they're really not if that's a joke it's
a pretty good joke but i suspect that's
not the joke it's counterproductive
i do think i have to quit comedy though
i mean yes i i
you know i i think i think maybe we
we can reach a consensus on that point
hannah
i think we could really come together as
a nation and unite around that i do
i do but let's um let's let's just get
to the rest of this bit
i'm we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
play this one to the end we're gonna do
it all right
and i i've built a career out of
self-deprecating humor
that's what i've built my career on and
i don't want to do that anymore because
do you understand
do you understand what self-deprecation
means when it comes from somebody who
already exists in the margins
it's not humility it's humiliation
i put myself down in order to speak
in order to seek permission to speak
and i simply will not do that anymore
not to myself
or anybody who identifies with me
i've had planters warts that were
funnier than that
and to top off the unfunniness there's
also just the the whininess
the woe is me stuff go back to the to
the last shot there the still shot of
her and the audience
hannah says she's on the margins she's
marginalized no you're not that's not
what marginalized looks like you have a
netflix deal
you're not marginalized you should be
marginalized as an unfunny comedian that
should be a marginalized demographic
but it's not i mean that's one of the
most lucrative
demographics going right now you're the
opposite of marginalized
there's a whole audience of people who
are watching they
paid money to watch you for some reason
i don't know why i don't know why they'd
pay money for that then again people
used to pay jack kevorkian so
and actually i'm kind of suspecting it's
a very similar audience
but you're not marginalized you're just
not that's all
get over it so i failed this challenge
but it's not my fault um like any good
millennial i refuse to take
responsibility for this whatsoever
i you know i'm i tried to laugh but i'm
leaving infuriated
and annoyed which is exactly how i went
in to be to be honest with you
um it's how i live every day of my life
so maybe that's part of the problem
but the point is i am a victim for
having endured this i am also now
marginalized and you're a victim too
so which is a good thing to be these
days so you're welcome
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen
[Music]